انصار الحزب الحاكم في نيجرها
حزب مؤتمر كل التقدميين
احتفلوا بفوز مرشحهم احمد بوليتينيبو
برئاسه البلاد وقد سلمته اللجنه الوطنيه
المستقله للانتخابات شهاده بذلك
2023 نزيهه وحره والمنافسه فيها حاده لم
تزيف النتائج عملنا بجد وقد تعلق كثير من
الناس بمرشحنا
المنافس الرئيسي مرشح حزب الشعب
الديمقراطي اتيكو ابو بكر حصل على نحو
سبعه ملايين سور
ويحظى بشعبيه في اوساط الشباب بشكل خاص
لكنه احزاب اخرى يقولون ان اعلان لجنه
الانتخابات فوز تيمبو شهاده حقيقيه على
انتخابات مزيفه
يهتم هذا التاجر بالسياسه في موسم
الانتخابات وحسب وهو لا يوافق على اعلان
فوز مرشح الحزب الحاكم
سياسيون بشكل عام لا يؤدون واجباتهم تجاه
الشعب واعلان رئيس لجنه الانتخابات لا
يتطابق ابدا مع ما ادلى به الناخبون شارك
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه 18 مرشحا لكن
التنافس انحصر بين مرشحي الحزب الحاكم
وحزب الشعب الديمقراطي وحزب العمل سلمت
لجنه الانتخابات شهاده الفوز لمرشح لحزب
الحاكم بمنصب رئاسه ناجرها لكن منافسيه
رفعوا لافته اتهام بالتزوير مجمل العمليه
الانتخابيه ونتائجها ومع الجدل المحتدم
هناك مخاوف من ان تؤدي هذه الاتهامات الى
العنف في البلد الذي يواجه اضطرابات
الامنيه
منذ اكثر من اقدم فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
ابوجا